okay openc the nft platform uh the
marketplace
uh has given an update
about the insider trading uh front
running however we wanna frame uh this
behavior
openc updated the original blog post we
covered this on wednesday's show
announcing that an employee who was
involved
in insider trading uh of nfts has
resigned here's the quote from the blog
we have a strong obligation to this
community to move forward move it
forward responsibly and diligently
that's a
you know a nothing sentence
uh the behavior of one of our employees
violated that obligation
okay they're admitting that this
occurred and yesterday we requested and
accepted his resignation uh that would
be the lowest form of sanction is that
you accepted their resignation i'm kind
of disappointed by that here's another
quote we do not take this behavior
lightly if you're just accepting his
resignation i think you do um upon
learning of this conduct we immediately
commissioned a third party to conduct a
thorough review of the incident and make
recommendations on how we can strengthen
our existing controls that review is
ongoing but we are committed quickly
implementing its recommendations so that
quote is a standard uh pr tactic we
hired an outside investigator here's how
it actually works because i've been
involved in this before you hire this
outside investigator those investigators
who do they report to
who pays their bill
okay
openc pays their bill they report to the
ceo on the board of uh openc
those shareholders are uh
can take that report and throw it away
if they don't agree with it they don't
have to act on it they can create a
second report they can do whatever they
want with these reports
the fact is what this person did was
really dirty and it really is gonna
tarnish uh the entire space because if
one person did this i'm almost certain
10 other people did
and so the actual response should be we
are going to pursue legal action against
this employee
um you probably should if you are a
trading platform and somebody is
screwing me
uh folks in your marketplace literally
this person was screwing the buyers and
sellers in the marketplace you should
pursue some legal uh options i know
that's hard to say but when somebody
steals or does something like this the
actual uh way to take the behavior
lightly is to let them resign
um you want to take legal action that's
what they should have done here they
should have pursued it with the
authorities there might not be anything
you can pursue i don't know if this is
exactly legal because openc and other
folks are claiming these are not
securities so it's not a security and
how is it exactly insider trading they
just bought a
would be like buying a comic book
that you knew was going to be promoted
by marvel comics and then holding it the
problem is these nfts are accelerating
in cost on the first day so this is more
like that story we had of the nike vice
president
and she was uh her son was buying all
the you know shoe drops before they came
out this is more along that so more
along that line um open seas response
timeline they found out in quotes about
the employee actions on tuesday
forced their resignation on wednesday
and announced they will potentially
pursue legal action changing their
anti-front-running control so maybe they
will pursue it i
give their response here like a six um
they didn't mention
investigating all other employees and
checking to see if anybody else had done
this i bet you somebody else i would say
dollars to donuts 60 70 percent chance
somebody else in the company's done this
or somebody else's family members have
done this so
while this person got caught
you know somebody could have just told
their family member their cousin their
friend from college hey go buy a bunch
of these for me they're going to be huge
and we'll flip them two days later and
chop the money up so um there's probably
some other stuff that's going on here
that's my best guess but i'm saying yes
as well now in more nft news nfts have
captured people's imagination because
people will buy them and they're
basically worthless digital assets the
only value they have is the value that
is bestowed upon them by collectors so
there's no intrinsic value in any of
these uh essentially um maybe somebody
can tell me if there is one that comes
with
rights to borrow uh you know a boat or
something or you know people are selling
nfts for time on private jets or you
know usage of an actual real world
private club i'm not sure if they do um
so
in more nft news jc damon dash
his co-founder at rockefeller records
over auctioning off copyright to jay-z's
debut album as an nft
so this is going to get really
complicated so in june jayce's
rockefeller records sued its co-founder
dame dash after hearing about dash's
plans to auction off his stake in the
company as an nft now why would be if he
has a stake in the company does that
stake in the company
come with
uh residuals to that album is there any
value to it do you have a voting
mechanism is this company active and are
these rights active who knows
in july dame dash launched an auction
with a starting bid of 10 million for
his one-third share of rockefeller is
one third share of reasonable down and a
commemorative nft representing the
certificate of ownership this is the nft
it looks terrible um and it says it's
the rock it's the diamond you get the
idea
uh quote from the website damon dash is
auctioning his one-third interest in
rockefeller inc which owns reasonable
doubt jay-z's first album i don't know
what it owns does it own all the rights
to it can you then sell the songs on
reasonable doubt to a movie um and get
one-third of the fees so if somebody
wants to use it in a tv show i.e
licensing or have those rights been sold
the highest bidder will also receive the
commemorative nft it's the rock
representing certificate of ownership
the bloomberg article explains the
convoluted legal argument as quote
rockefeller says that while daesh holds
a one-third stake in the company it owns
the album itself and he has no legal
right to sell the nft essentially
rockefeller saying dash has no right
to mint a stake in the record company or
the album itself is an nft and sell it
and i'll just add here like i think
they're trying to screw the person who's
buying it like what are they actually
buying you're buying yourself into a
lawsuit
um seems pretty dumb to me a dash was
blocked from selling rights to the album
and agreed to wait till the lawsuit was
resolved before continuing the auction
according to bloomberg
uh the bloomberg article quoted dash's
lawyer who stated that quote dash is
just trying to assign the rights to
future royalties he's entitled to as one
third owner rockefeller as artists have
done for a long time so i guess you are
getting the rights to future royalties
you get all of them you get them up
until the price you paid for 10 million
and then you split them i don't know
what the contract here is lawsuits
ongoing so dash's nft auction has been
put on hold
um so
i mean he's talking about selling
his stake which would be securities
as an nft and we have this discussion or
nfts securities well this one is
specifically designed to
act like uh and represent a security so
this one for sure is a security
are other ones a security or are they a
trading card that just happens to
accumulate a lot of value um to
celebrate the 25th anniversary of
reasonable doubt his debut album jay-z
sold his own nft vice otherwise for 138k
uh on sotheby's website it knows the nft
was on sale from june 25th to july
second with a starting bid of 1000
and it's a slightly better looking um
nft i guess
um
yeah i mean this is the wild west nfts
basically people are looking at them and
saying this is a way for me to get
somebody with a bunch of crypto money to
give me that crypto money and i give
them back a jpeg that
really has
you know probably little to no value and
if it acts like a security
and uh
you know i guess it's a security it's
really hard to tell in these cases
um because these are something new
they're not exactly securities but if
people are buying them because they
increase in value
and you're selling collections of them
your marketplaces
i can see people making an argument they
are um
and they can obviously be used for all
kinds of
um money laundering
and a washing of money that was obtained
illegally
so you know these are this is a really
um interesting dangerous weird
thing that has occurred so if you're
into this nft space and you've made a
ton of money suggest doing a little
profit taking have fun out there
um but if it's 99 of your net worth and
you can buy a house with half the money
um or pay off your college debt that's
never a bad thing to do i wish you luck
be careful out there
have fun you know consider it like
gambling
when you are trying to grow a startup
fast hiring engineers will slow you down
like nothing else don't i know it so
many companies i invest in are telling
me they can't get their next version out
because they don't have a great engineer
well lemon.io will find you a perfect
candidate in just 48 hours it's a
marketplace of engineers from europe and
they test and interview every developer
to eliminate the risk of a failed
project lemon io is the perfect solution
if you are a technical co-founder and
you need to delegate some of your
important tasks or you have a project
that needs specific technology and you
don't have that skill on your team yet
or you are just growing so fast that you
need to add more developers and get more
done faster they'll match you with a
candidate within 48 hours and if it
doesn't work out they'll replace the
developer right away so here is your cta
the old call to action if you could use
a full-time or even part-time developer
to run your projects faster go to lemon
dot io slash twist once again lemon l e
m o n dot io slash twist and you'll
receive a 15 discount for the first four
weeks of work with that amazing
developer well done lemon okay check it
out everybody lemon.iho twist